Tom who will get in tomorrow into the
Baseball Hall of Fame well the
announcement later on today I know well
I don't know but I pretty sure Jeff
Bagwell and Tim Raines are going in then
the question is who gets in if anybody
else after that it's going to be real
close between lad Guerrero and Trevor
Hoffman you need 75 percent of vote to
get in and those guys will be really
really close to that number Tom will be
part of MLB network's exclusive Hall of
Fame coverage beginning today at three
Eastern the election announcement will
be at six Eastern what happens first
bonds and Clemens go in or Curt
Schilling the great question you come up
with the best questions I you know what
I it probably bonds and Clemens have a
better shot and I wouldn't it not have
said that last year but I can see things
changing then the biggest thing that
jumped out to me this year is so far 12
first-year voters have their ballots
have been identified 11 of those 12 have
voted for bonds and Clemens and you're
talking about two guys who never got
over fifty percent now they're trending
ninety-two percent with first-time
voters and that tells me the younger
guys who didn't cover the steroid era
don't care about peds what do you think
is guy because I think that this voting
this could be the most important ballot
we've ever had in the Hall of Fame
history and maybe I'm overstating it but
if we start to look at bonds and Clemens
creeping up towards that sixty-five
percent or 60 or even close to 70
whatever it's going to be what's it mean
for these other players you know down
you know the next couple of ballots here
am I overstating the importance of the
voting in regards to steroid users no I
think you're right and I think one of
the keys you mentioned this do they get
over sixty percent again they haven't
been over fifty percent yet so that
would be a big leap and I think if they
get over 60 with five more cracks on the
ballot good chance they get those last
remaining fifteen percent or so to get
in and then you make a great point what
do we do about guys who are on or off
the ballot already like Mark McGwire do
we go back and take a mulligan and those
guys who are kept out because of TD de
diez
so yes I don't expect those guys to get
in this year or next year I will say it
gets harder to climb the mountain the
higher up you get so getting closer to
75 percent is going to be really tough
for those guys but if they take a
significant jump this year it looks like
they might yes you're talking about
something that could be historically
significant so important is character as
a factor here for the Hall of Fame only
tell you something like character day
and people take this out of context and
we start whoo are we to decide how guys
live their lives know this to me this is
about how you played on the field the
integrity of how you played the game
between the lines I don't care what you
do before the game or after the game but
did you play the game fairly that is to
me what character is all about and
that's why I don't vote for P ed guys
they willingly cheated the game they
knew they were playing on an uneven
playing field and they made that
conscious choice so much so that they
had to hide it from everybody even to
this day so to me when you talk about
character you're talking about how did
you play the game I also look at Curt
Schilling that will call into question
his character because of what he's
tweeted or what his feelings are about a
lot of issues where we're not going to
call into question the guys who cheated
while they're playing the game so the
likely if you're going to weigh out
character I'm going to weigh out what
you did in the game to the game as
opposed to what you did after you played
the game and Schilling is not under any
steroid cloud here I find it a little
hypocritical that we're going to
question Schilling more than we would
bonds and Clemens I agree a hundred
percent now I have voted for Curt
Schilling I think he's a hall-of-famer
you know some of the dumb things that he
has said or tweeted do not change my
opinion of him as a baseball player now
if he does something actionable off the
field in terms of lawlessness or
something that really is heinous yeah I
take a hard look at that and let's say
you can do absolutely anything but yes
in terms of thing and don't thank dump
things and having outlier opinions that
doesn't change who he is as a baseball
player and that's what I'm voting on I'm
also wondering where you stand on this
that writers have you know we're making
that sharp
turn here where were all of a sudden
looking at steroid users differently but
my thought is it is a museum and if you
want to put them in and tell the history
of baseball fine I also think if you
tested positive if there's documentation
like Manny Ramirez does not get in and
Alex Rodriguez does not get in do you
have any problem with that if we have to
have some line of demarcation here from
2003 on let's say if you test you tested
positive you're not getting into the
whole thing now I don't have a problem
with that in fact some of the writers
are saying hey Hall of Fame give us some
guidelines here give us some voting
instructions I don't need voting
instructions to know that you know
especially well as you said we have
these rules in place and you're clearly
violating these rules there's no way you
should be a Hall of Famer so I wouldn't
have a problem if that was actually
legislated in its part of the voting
procedure but I do agree it's a it's a
solid line to me you know you can say
it's a blurry one before 2003 but since
we went to steroid testing it was part
of the rules of the game everybody knew
about so I don't think the Hall of Fame
Dan would go down that path to say here
are your voting instructions guys I
think they liked it the way that it is
it partly because it creates a lot of
discussion and controversy but I
wouldn't have a problem with that yeah
it's tough you know I don't envy you
guys in it and look I take great pride
in awards that I voted on or voting on
the Heisman but when it comes to this it
it feels like no matter what you do you
didn't do the right job it's a great
point and you know what it is less fun
than it used to be and it is hard but
because it's hard then doesn't mean you
run away from it and I mean if you're
sitting on a jury say in a civil trial
it's a very tough case you don't throw
your hands up and say message is too
tough I'm out of here no you make a
decision based on the preponderance of
evidence this is not a criminal trial
where you're throwing people in jail and
innocent until proven guilty and it's
beyond a reasonable doubt it's
preponderance of evidence and for me I
consider only public evidence not
suspicion innuendo rumor eyeball test
what's out there publicly that I the
journalists can write connecting
somebody to peds if the evidence is
there I'm not voting for you and
doesn't change it it will not change
based on some committee or some other
writers opinion which player playing now
feels most like a first ballot well
breaking news when Clayton Kershaw
throws his first pitch of this year he's
a hall-of-famer because you need a ten
year minimum and this will be his tenth
season even with one pitch and he'd get
it all right now he could stop after the
first pitch nothing walked off the field
and say I'm done and he's got my vote
for the Hall of Fame because it's almost
like Sandy Koufax you know you don't
have that longevity but you're talking
about big the best pitcher in the game
for almost a decade I'm putting up just
ridiculous numbers that's the definition
of a first-ballot hall-of-famer and the
other thing that is you know next year
every vote it will be announced you know
who you voted for now it's just at your
own discretion whether you release your
ballot or not so what we're going to see
are people who are going to be unanimous
because of three people who did not vote
for junior Griffey we still don't know
who they are it's probably because
somebody didn't want to be known as the
person who didn't put them on the ballot
now you can't run and hide so whether
it's Mariano Rivera or Derek Jeter we
will see a unanimous first ballot
hall-of-famer but do you think because
these writers made a mistake in the
early going where you didn't vote babe
ruth unanimous therefore it's all of a
sudden you know how can we vote you
unanimous when we didn't do this to babe
ruth or Hank Aaron or Willie Mays or
some of the other greats of the game
yeah it's me that's not a good enough
reason I mean just because it wasn't
right then doesn't mean it's you know
right today or but how do you not vote
for somebody I don't know how somebody
says Hank Aaron I don't know man or Tom
Seaver Ken Griffey jr. I just don't know
how you can rationalize that unless you
want to be that guy who's the contrarian
I'm with you brother III don't
understand that there's no defense to it
other than yes if your grandstanding and
one attention to yourself now apparently
that was not the case of the three
people didn't vote for junior Griffey
because nobody said hey Here I am guys
come talk to me about my outlier vote us
but I don't get it i mean what motivates
somebody to leave someone like that
who's a clear first ballot hall-of-famer
off the ballot I mean what's going to
happen
with Jeter and with Rivera what defense
could you possibly have because you will
need a public defense if you don't put
them on the ballot have fun later today
tom thanks Dan is Tom Verducci the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]